[Music]
[Applause]
can you recall the last time you saw a
movie that pierced you so deeply you
felt the urge to continuously watch it
over and over until it no longer felt
like a film but instead had blossomed
into something else entirely
while doing research for my ghost in the
shell' reviews I decided to watch films
made by Mamoru Oshii that I had never
seen I loved his work on ghosts in the
show and Jinro which he wrote but hadn't
yet seen a few of his films like
Patlabor talking-head or the sky
crawlers that's how I came across
angel's egg or tenshi no tamago as it's
known in Japan and I don't think my
brain has quite recovered since I became
so obsessed with this film that I even
hired a translator to go through this
book which is a collection of
storyboards from the movie containing
notes from the original artist this
helps me understand the film even more
it also fully solidified my nerd card
which was in desperate need of renewal
angel's egg reminds me of a film I would
have scrolled past on the sci-fi channel
back in the 90s at 3:00 a.m. and gotten
unexpectedly entranced by it feels like
a drug-induced trip of psychedelic
imagery while also being relentlessly
meaningful the deceptively simple story
is as follows a young girl roams a
wasteland that resembles a
post-apocalyptic earth she carries with
her an egg that we learn she's very
protective of she meets a man who joins
her on this journey who may be friend or
foe this plot is decidedly free of
conventional drama character tropes are
really anything we've come to expect
from traditional filmmaking let alone
anime before I go any further I must
warn you this will be a spoiler filled
discussion of angels ik I'm willing to
bet that many of you have never seen
this film and for that reason I implore
you to do so if you can find the film
please see it if you like weird trippy
movies with profound implications that
use visuals to tell their story instead
of dialogue angel's egg will problem
we do it for you I love analyzing
unknown films like this like most
recently would stay but it's unfortunate
that a large number of my audience
probably hasn't seen it I truly hope you
give the film a shock also another
warning this film is steeped in heavy
religious themes and I'll obviously be
discussing them if that's something that
makes you a little uncomfortable and
this definitely is not a film for you
some have attempted to analyze Angels
egg in the past I'm certainly not the
first to do so but there is an
unfortunate lack of information about
this film on the net which is at once
surprising yet also expected I think
this film is just as good as oh she's
more well known ghost in the shell' but
I also recognize that a film this
difference that really contains no
concrete answers to its philosophical
questions will likely divide audiences
even oshi himself has been quoted as
saying he doesn't know what the film is
about it's wholly possible that angel's
egg is meant to be taken purely as an
art film with no concrete interpretation
actually being correct but I do have one
very specific thing that I've gleaned
from the film I'd like to discuss faith
while doing research on the making of
angel's egg I learned that oh she
dedicated much of his life to studying
religion specifically Christianity he
originally considered attending seminary
before he turned to directing the large
majority of his films all contain heavy
religious themes Patlabor features an
investigation surrounding a culprit who
uses biblical phrases and passages as
clues to his crimes the puppet master
and ghost in the shell' often quote
Scripture as well but for unknown
reasons he apparently had a falling out
with his states before production on
angels egg began armed with this
information this movie took on a whole
new meaning for me the film opens with a
young man overlooking a vast space as a
large ominous orb resembling an eye
descends towards him this orb is covered
in various statues that are in
subservient poses as if they are praying
we hear a girl ask this question
dang I got God daddy the noise from this
machine awakens this young girl who
overlooks the empty surroundings of this
world Angels egg contains a great deal
of Christian symbolism so much in fact
that it's unmistakable if you know what
to look for this isn't something I've
discussed much mainly because it doesn't
often pertain to movie reviews but I've
studied theology a great deal in my life
having explored many beliefs and
cultures perhaps that's why angels egg
appealed to me so much the young girl
wanders the wasteland carrying her egg
collecting jars of water at first I
thought she was simply saving water to
drink but later it's revealed that she's
been preserving vast amounts of these
jars water is ever-present in this film
and plays a large part in the story
water is famously viewed as pure in
Christianity or holy and it gets brought
up again later which we'll discuss as
she fills a jar she received a vision of
herself engulfed in water which
terrifies her soon large tank like
vehicles pass by the girl and the man
emerges from them approaching her
quietly she flees from him at first but
quickly returns to find that he's
disappeared she soon goes back to
collecting water before running away in
fear I believe she became frightened
upon seeing these statues that surround
this fountain since they are shown
clearly after she runs away soon the man
returns brandishing her egg which she
accidentally left behind
she takes back the egg and keep in mind
that despite having the opportunity the
man did not break or steal the egg in
one of the most breathtaking sequences
in the film the same statute that scared
the young girl earlier come to life and
begin to hunt the shadows of large fish
they throw ropes Spears at the ghostly
fish unable to capture them despite
their extreme efforts the young girl
says cocoon Yamuna
I cook it up how governor cook when you
mine are you many have speculated that
this is a metaphor for blind faith the
chasing of it and the fruitlessness of
never being able to harness it or
capture it - oh she it seems space is an
illusory facade that despite our
vigorous efforts we'll never be able to
capture as the fisherman attempts to
they destroy the world around them oh
she seems to be suggesting that religion
is the cause of considerable conflict
and strife but that people will never
stop chasing after it no matter how
futile their efforts become during this
scene the girl is seen admiring a large
glass window of the very same fish
inside a church like structure this also
seems to indicate that chasing after
these fish is in some way related to
obtaining some form of enlightenment to
add to the biblical symbolism followers
of Christ were often referred to as
fishermen in the Bible but in that case
the meaning was more derived from the
idea that Christ wanted his followers to
preach to become fishers of men
nevertheless the symbolism here wasn't
lost on me the girl leads the man back
to a place she frequents a large
structure containing many fossilized
remains of animals the man recounts a
lost memory of a bird and an egg an
image we saw at the very start of the
film soon the two of them both share a
loss of memory both characters seem to
be going through the motions completing
some sort of task yet unsure of why
they've been assigned it then in the
film's largest dialogue scene the man
recounts the story of Noah's Ark if
you're familiar with the tale you know
that it tells the story of a great flood
that filled the earth and one large boat
built by Noah to preserve the animal
species eventually Noah sent out a dove
which returned with an olive branch
signifying that it was safe to leave the
ark the man's story in this film
deviates from the Bible and suggests
that Noah and his family waited so long
for the Dove to return that they forgot
what they were waiting for they grew old
and lost all sense of time and place
demand suggests that he feels this way
unsure of the world around him and if
his memories are reality or fiction the
girl takes him to a large fossil of a
bird one that resembles the bird in his
memory
he seems shocked by the revelation that
this memory isn't false she then
explains that she believes a similar
bird is in her egg and she's waiting for
it to hatch the next shot is extremely
telling in fact it's the most telling
shot in the film a wide shot reveals
that our characters are taking shelter
in an arc in fact I'm willing to bet
that literally is supposed to be Noah's
Ark we're shown skeletal remains of
animals everywhere as well as a wide
shot detailing the many rooms in this
Ark likely meant for the housing of
animals it seems that in oshi's film
he's suggesting that the blind faith
Noah instilled in God was never fully
rewarded that the animals on board all
died and eventually they grew old for
getting what they were doing there in
the first place
now this young girl firmly grasping her
egg and the man who both can't recall
what their purpose is
wander this wasteland searching for a
meaning before the girl falls asleep she
says she can hear the baby bird in the
egg breathing yet the man insists it's
just the wind her faith that this egg
will hatch is unshakable despite his
suggesting that it unwarranted one last
time she asks the man who he is but this
time he responds with the same question
right back to her we see next that the
water is growing around them the rain
seems to be unstoppable despite the girl
collecting it in jars after an absurdly
long wide shot the man finally gets up
steals her egg and crushes it with his
weapon then we seed the town has become
even more surrounded by water as the
rain continues when the girl finds her
egg shattered she emits a horrifying
scream and begins chasing after the man
she falls into a ravine and before
hitting the water she sees her
reflection
if she's matured into a woman a similar
image was seen in oh she's second
masterpiece ghost in the show as this
girl dies she unleashes as if from her
belly more eggs that float to the top of
the water soon they are protruding from
the ground as in the vision scene at the
start of the film and the one described
in the man's memory now the man stands
on a beach surrounded by white feathers
which were also seen and ghost in the
shell' I might add the same godlike eye
we saw in the beginning emerges from the
sea to greet the man and were shown the
praying statues again except this time a
monument of the girl holding her egg is
included amongst the sea of statues in
one final reveal we zoom out from the
beach discovering that this world we've
been in is simply an island floating in
the middle of a vast sea of nothingness
some have speculated this appears to be
an overturned Ark abandoned out to sea
some have suggested this reveals that we
are in fact witnessing a world where the
great flood occurred yet earth was not
repopulated oh she himself has been
quoted as saying that the meaning of a
film is up to the viewer not the
director in this case I have a lot to
say let's break the film down piece by
piece it's imperative to remember that
the heavy Christian symbolism is
extremely important in deciphering where
is head was that while he made this film
even if there isn't a definitive answer
the film has become clearer to me when
analyzed from the perspective that oh
she was dealing with a major crisis of
faith while making this movie I believe
the young man in this film represents
Christ and this giant orb is likely God
or the eye of God the man carries a
large device on his shoulder this easily
recognizable as the shape of a cross and
if that's not enough of a hint his hands
are bandaged in the same place Christ
was likely crucified the young girl and
her egg seems to be a metaphor for the
innocence of blind faith in one very
telling scene she says she's positive
she can hear the bird inside the egg
breathing even when the man suggests
that
where she's hearing is just the wind
nothing can convince her otherwise to
her that bird is in the egg and it will
hatch it seems that this is oh she's
commentary on religion and faith in
general the idea that belief in a higher
power despite having no tangible proof
that it exists is based entirely on
faith no matter what anyone else may
tell you the girl is very protective of
her egg as our people of their beliefs
early on in the film the man has an
opportunity to break the egg but instead
gives it back stating that she should
keep things precious inside her so if he
planned to break the egg the whole time
why didn't he just do it then to
understand what oh she may have been
suggesting looking back on certain
biblical examples could help there are
many stories in the Bible of God giving
various assignments or tests to his
servants God allowing Satan to a flipped
joke Abraham being instructed to kill
his own son or even Jesus fasting for 40
days in the wilderness in all cases
after being proved worthy of the test
the individual is greatly rewarded for
their steadfastness in this case the
girl's faith is being tested she wanders
this world collecting water unsure of
why she's doing it
unsure of the passage of time protecting
an egg that she fiercely believes will
hatch the man suggests at one point
opening the egg and yet she still
refuses he finally suggests to her that
her faith is false and that she's simply
hearing what she wants to hear when she
still denies this he breaks the egg
himself she flees after him in horror
falling into a ravine figuratively
maturing into a woman having been broken
her innocent and blind faith violated
the book stray dog of anime the films of
Mamoru Oshii written by Brian ruff had
this to say about a relationship between
the girl and man portrayed in the film
angels egg is the girl's coming-of-age
story it is the encounter between a girl
represented by the egg she carries and a
man first introduced aside and masculine
tank although the girl asks the soldier
to do no harm to that which is most
precious to her the egg
he takes it from her while she is
sleeping when he smashes the egg with a
weapon that is simultaneously phallic
and like the Christian cross the girl's
innocence is destroyed along with her
faith in the egg water is an often
employed symbol of femininity in
Japanese culture and it is into water
that the girl falls after her egg has
been destroyed she then seemingly gives
birth to many more eggs
perhaps reaping her reward for
maintaining faith these eggs grow into
birds like in the man's vision affirming
her beliefs and she's eventually
memorialized on the godlike orb having
become Saint like there's another theory
I have about these characters one that I
haven't seen discussed anywhere to my
knowledge it's possible that oh she is
exploring the belief of reincarnation
that of one soul coming back to life
after death in another person or form
there are many hints to this possibility
present in the film and one that was
staring me right in the face both the
girl and a man seemed to have lost
memory gaps in their subconscious the
man sees a drawing of a large tree and
reflects on a vague memory of having
seen it before in what little dialogue
the film has both characters discussed
the feeling of having forgotten
something about themselves as if they're
both suffering from a monumental case of
deja vu these are common traits for
people who believe they've been
reincarnated vague memories of a distant
life often plagued these individuals
there's even an x-files episode about it
called the field where I died the
biggest clue though can be found on the
film's official soundtrack under track
number 13 this track is the music
featured in the scene where the girl
dies giving birth to many eggs which
eventually become Birds the track name
when translated into English is
literally transmigration which if you
know your theology is simply another
term for reincarnation so if the
reincarnation angle is correct are we
looking at a real
coronated form of Christ and the young
man he seems to have a vague memory of
the Tree of Life and when he sees the
fossil of the giant bird he undergoes
some form of awakening as if his mission
has become clear or he remembers what he
must do in the Bible Jesus underwent a
similar rebirth upon his baptism
realizing his mission on earth Matthew
3:16 speaks of the heavens opening up to
Jesus upon being baptized in water as if
all had become clear to him I don't
think it's a coincidence that after the
man steps into water becoming soaked by
it that he appears to come to a
realization it's directly after this
that the man destroyed her egg as if he
was recalling some assignment he was
once given but had forgotten about was
this his directive in the start of the
film as he awaited the godlike eye while
standing on a chess board of sorts was
he sent to meet this girl to reaffirm
her faith and his is he simply a pawn of
his God as indicated by the checkered
board he stands on this is where things
split in two for me
there are two ways you can do this the
positive viewpoint is that the girl kept
her faith despite the continual testing
of it then the christ-like man releases
her from her test and she reaps one
hundredfold what she had before in the
process realizing that her faith was
true
since the birds she envisioned grow from
her eggs eventually she's memorialized
in the godlike structure as someone to
be praised or honored the negative
viewpoint is that despite trusting in
her faith and going about her tasks
without question her beliefs were
betrayed nonetheless and she's left to
die after her spiritual violation the
reason that I don't give as much weight
to this cynical viewpoint is due to the
ending despite how much of this film is
left ambiguous one thing that seems
clear to me is that she is now in a
position of Honor I believe the message
that oh she is sending is simply how
unclear and divisive states can be in
his case
he seems to have dealt with a
considerable doubt in his beliefs and
has made a gorgeous film that examines
what one goes through when dealing with
a crisis of faith just as the girl
continuously asks the man who he is
it seems oh she yearns to understand his
faith until finally the man asks the
girl the same question right back oh she
is perhaps hinting that faith is simply
a process of discovering who we are what
we are and what we can become
I think angel's egg is an undisputed
masterpiece there's not a single film
like it in live-action and certainly not
an animation it's a film so ambitious
and unconventional that nearly any
interpretation can be considered correct
oh she has clearly made a film steeped
in heavy themes and imagery that's meant
to impact everyone differently what do
you see in angels egg lastly it's
painful to me that this film hasn't
received a proper release in America it
has been released on blu-ray in Japan
which is the transfer I used for this
video the DVD currently listed on Amazon
is very hard to come by and I've heard
no plans for a blu-ray release so what
do I propose The Criterion Collection
they've already released adult-oriented
animations like watership down and
fantastic planet angels egg seems like
something they should rescue do you
believe this film should be preserved do
you think it's an overlooked masterpiece
as I do then join me in contacting
criterion to get this film properly
released in America email them at
suggestions at criterion comm and CC
John Mulvaney from criterion at Mulvaney
at criterion comm let them know this
film is perfect for them you can also
tweet at criterion maybe we'll see a
release of this masterpiece yet guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I love doing these analog videos I
especially love doing them for films
that aren't necessarily new releases
they're tons of fun to make and I really
appreciate sharing more in depth
thoughts with you guys thank you so much
as always for watching
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuff mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]